[Music]
jamie joins us in philadelphia
pennsylvania jamie welcome to the ramsay
show
what's going on guys hey how can we help
so i've been listening to you guys for
the past couple weeks but um i've yet to
read and like look into the steps for
financial peace i guess um i'm 19 years
old and i plan on buying my first duplex
pretty soon but i'm going to be
purchasing with the mortgage
um i plan on like i've been hearing from
a lot of you guys to stay out of like
debt but i also heard from other sources
to stay out of
bad debt
so i was just curious like what is the
difference
of like
bad debt and good day i guess i mean i
plan on renting out both sides of
duplexes so i'm gonna have some casual
on top of it but
yeah i'm just pretty much curious
so i guess that's pretty much yeah so
jamie i'll say what the world says what
the culture is saying when they're
saying quote unquote good debts
it's usually in purposes of an
investment you know people say well
student loans are good debt because it's
an investment in yourself
they'll talk about a mortgage being good
debt or if you're taking data on your
business because you're gonna make money
so like that's the way the world kind of
operates when it comes to the system but
here at ramsey
i'll just tell you we're pretty weird
and so we say all debts all debt
is bad debt now a mortgage i'll say this
with the asterisk a mortgage is the one
type of debts that we will not yell at
you for on your primary mortgage so
other than that though and the reason
why jamie is because
one of your largest wealth building tool
tools out there is your income and for a
lot of people
78 of americans are living paycheck to
paycheck and the money comes in their
income does and it's going out on
average 500 something dollars to car to
a car payment they're paying their
student loans average family has 16 000
of credit card debt i mean like their
income is leaving so there is no margin
in their life to do things like giving
investing saving even spending on what
they want
in order to do those things they have to
go deeper in debt right so it's like the
cycle that ends up playing and then what
we have found too is over the course of
time that cycle just wears on you
emotionally spiritually
financially you're just not able to seem
to get traction and so
the idea of avoiding debt
completely
gives you power it gives you control it
gives you choices when you don't owe
anyone anything
and you want to quit your job and move
to another job you can because you don't
have bills like there there is something
powerful when you don't owe money to
anyone
um that would be my take and george you
yeah yeah well jamie the thing is the
people who tell you there is such thing
at good debt they don't pay your bills
you do and so when it comes down to debt
really it's stealing from your income
and so i know you want to get into this
duplex and you're 19. i mean that's
that's very impressive yeah it is
absolutely and i think it's awesome that
you want to do this uh but i i would
challenge you to go against the grain
when it comes to pretty much anything
society
says uh so when it comes to good debt
versus bad debt yes we do believe that
all debt is bad because it steals from
your income that your that you work
really hard for do you have any debt
right now
um i mean i went to trade school um and
i ended up paying like it was like 25
000 total so yeah i do have debt but i
make 80k a year so it's like wow what do
you do i'm curious it was an investment
um
it's hvac so heating ventilation air
conditioning
but wow i mean
that's why i didn't look at it as like
too terrible and that's why i'm calling
you today because
exactly like if you guys think that like
investments like if you're buying a
mortgage to like maybe make some more
money you know and it's not necessarily
a bad thing like say i get the house for
under market value and it's worth more
than i've paid like
that's what i was pretty much curious
about obviously you guys helped me out a
lot so i appreciate it thank you no
absolutely and i'll just kind of tack on
to that jamie too that you know when it
comes to
people try to play the math game so much
when it comes to life and money right
and so that idea hey i'm gonna you know
people say well i'm gonna borrow on my
on my mortgage because i can actually
put that money in the market and borrow
against my house because the math works
i can make more and investing or i'm not
going to pay off my mortgage because you
know i mean like there's there's a math
games that we can play all day but one
thing jamie just to just to note that
people do not um
take life and risk into consideration
people don't take in 2008 when the
market completely crashed at the housing
market and people that had these
mortgages that thought they were okay
went into foreclosure people didn't
factor in a recession where entire
industries were out of work i mean there
are things that happen in life so the
the le when you don't have debt even a
mortgage but when you don't have debt
you don't have risk
and there is something about that that
is that is huge and
you know and even the student loan
um idea and i know you went to trade
school you said and you took out money
and it was investment you and all that
you know which which is great i don't
want to shame you for any of that but
also pushing people to think differently
to know that i can actually go get an
education i can actually go to trade
school
and and do things that i don't have to
take out debt so we really do here at
ramsey we we push against
these messages because what we have
found time and time again
is that people live with this debt and
it eats into their income and then it
eventually is this thief that it steals
your stre steals your peace of mind it
steals your sleep
and again there is something powerful
when you don't owe anyone anything yeah
rachel and we talk about this all the
time but the quickest way to building
wealth is to get back your greatest
wealth building tool which is your
income and so jamie i think it's awesome
you want to get this duplex but you're
telling me how you have this debt and
you're wanting to get into this
investment property or your primary
residence so i would challenge you with
this amazing income you have pay off all
of your debt first
get a fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses if you
don't already have that if you do have
some money sitting around attack the
student loan debt first that's baby step
two i know you've been listening just
for a few weeks now baby step three
you're gonna get that emergency fund in
place and then we call it three b is
where you save up for that down payment
on that house so we want you to do that
on a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage with a
payment that's no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay so a lot of numbers
there but all of this is so that you can
win with money so you don't have this
anxiety and burden in your life when
you're trying to do too many things at
once so that's the way to do it man
you're 19 you're making a great income
and shout out to the trades man 80k
you're 19 years old because you want to
way to go this is the ramsay show